okay so we have this convolution cyclic
peptide sequencing algorithm and it
works really well on the hypothetical
Specter that we've considered but these
spectra aren't necessarily a
representative of spectra that we might
encounter in practice
so in particular we had 25% false and
missing masses and that's much less
noisy than what we will be able to
obtain from practical spectrum also I've
I've said that the mass spectrometer is
is we can think of it as a scale but it
doesn't really just weigh the peptide
fragments it's a lot more complicated
than that what it does is first it
ionizes the peptide fragments so it
converts them into ions with a positive
or negative charge and then it sorts
these fragments using an electromagnetic
field once it does that it's then able
to not measure the mass but the mass
charge ratio of each fragment then it
determines the intensity or
approximately we'll think about it as
the number of ions at each matte charge
ratio value and so after it determines
this intensity at each mass charge ratio
value we're able to create a graph from
this and so this is really what the
spectrum is the spectrum is a graph of
the intensity on the y-axis and the mass
charge ratio on the x-axis so it's
detecting the number a give or take the
number of ions at each mass charge ratio
value and from this we somehow need to
convert it into mass right all we have
is mass charge ratio so these we want to
consider the most popular elements in
this or the most intense Peaks is what
will will is the term that we'll use and
the challenge is now to reconstruct in
this case to first convert to mass and
then use those masses to reconstruct the
peptide in a case where we may not have
25 percent false and missing masses we
may have like 2/3 of the masses prez
that are detected in our spectrum may be
false in which case we've got to really
switch up what we do and we may need to
adapt the algorithms that we have and so
on stepping this is where we give you
the example to take a real spectrum and
try to process it and adapt the
algorithms that you have maybe coming
with new ideas and try to sequence a
real peptide from a real experimental
spectrum